my favorite want to grow is cilantro
water spinach sour leaf and the squash
vines because these four are really the
main things my mom cook in Burmese
dishes
this part is really important to the
refugee people because they get to see
their friends they get to talk in their
language and they get to talk each other
their experience being in America
I thought everything will be easy like
how my mom said how fun it was when she
was little and then when I actually had
to experience it I was like it's really
hard and it's hot I would tell my mom
how are they doing it in Burma and I'll
always get tired and complain but I was
having fun